so now it's my pleasure to introduce our
sheet Patra who's going to talk about
enabling better pregnancy monitoring the
case of point-of-care diagnosis in Vito
Vito
echo echo cardiogram hello good
afternoon everybody
so I'm original verse 'ti of Oxford I
work at the Institute biomedical
engineering there and I mostly study
automation of federal to sound using
machine learning and computer vision and
biomechanical models so today I will
talk about bringing point of care
ultrasound for fetal echocardiography in
the light of recent introductions in
sorry so before we move into the
technicalities of it I would like to
have some motivation about why we do
vital ultrasound why fatal ultrasound
automation and what next for federal
ultrasound so the reason why fetal
ultrasound is so important is because
when you talk about prenatal health
monitoring or even growth assessments or
diagnosis of anomalies in the developing
fetus usage of other modalities like you
know imaging modalities like CT or MRI
are highly contentious while MRI can be
used but in most health systems due to
the process of heat generation or in
general irritability of the fetus to MRI
restricts it to not beyond six weeks so
ultrasound becomes the predominant
modality for anomaly scanning and I
focus primarily on monitoring of the
fatal heart reason being that congenital
heart diseases and associated
complications are a leading cause of
infant mortality and on 42% of infant
mortality worldwide can be accounted for
congenital heart disease all said and
done the human capital required to do
adequate health monitoring is not
particularly optimistic in India for
example there are 1 in 200,000
sonographers and when I say sonographers
I'm including a really broad definition
of sonographers who can do a basic
scanning protocol actual diagnosis of
CHD would require a lot more specialism
into
you have to be a cardiologist then you
have to specialize in fatal cardiology
so as such the upshot is that not only
is the capital expertise in capital
equipment in short supply so is the
human expertise and this is ripe Avenue
for disruption in the sense that if you
could automate fatal ultrasound
monitoring that would be a huge step
forward for achieving the goal of
healthcare for all at all ages
so we consider a case for fatal heart
assessments specifically we start with
the visibility and a viewing plane
assessment for a proof-of-concept of
deploying resource control constrained
ultrasound algorithms the reason why
ultrasound is so particularly
complicated as compared to you know
relatively friendlier modalities like
computed tomography or MRI is that a
most of the features that are observed
in ultrasound in the Fanning window are
really really small and are also
complicated by anatomical appearances in
a very short region on top of that there
is a predominance of speckle artifacts
enhancements stochastic presence of
shadows variations of contrast and all
of this is done in a really short time
where the sonographer who specifically
does the ultrasound has to juggle
through multiple responsibilities such
as viewing plane identification freezing
of images gender identification
counseling the patient and so on and so
forth and this specific aspect becomes
particularly pronounced in resource
constrained healthcare systems in India
China in Africa where the time allocated
per patient is way below global
standards we in this case talk about
fatal heart assessment which we model as
a video understanding problem analysis
in these cases can be frame level or can
be at the level of extended number of
frames over time so as to account for
the temporal aspects of the
understanding problem the specific tasks
that we demonstrate here is the viewing
plane classification and also the
identification of feasibility which is
basically a background frame is where
the heart is not visible the reason we
do that we specifically follow the is
Yoji guidelines and consider the four
chamber three vessel and LV ot views
Elvia t being left ventricular outflow
tract the rationale behind doing
that is that congenital heart diseases
are predominantly apparent in the fourth
chamber view with a minority of
conditions apparent in the other views
so the classification becomes force view
and non force view congenital heart
diseases so as a first step towards
congenital heart anomaly assessment you
need to do an identification of the
viewing planes
so we consider datasets with variable
video lanes variable frame rates between
25 to 76 fps there are multiple views in
some videos with a stochastic presence
of bragg round frames because the fetus
moves around very randomly when
subjected to ultrasound we do some
pre-processing like cropping to a
standard size we do data augmentation
for the video analysis we consider
continuous 8 frames and artificially
constructed video for training the
reason we look at point of care
specifically the aspect that motivates
us here is that very recently there have
been clear slight butterfly network and
carriers who have come up with mobile
probes now this is different from your
standard portable ultrasound scanners
these mobile probes and this was
demonstrated by specifically in the case
of butterfly network in late 2017 by
their founder where they scan his wrist
and it was apparent on his iPhone so
they allow a USB plug and play kind of a
system fundamentally they allow
conversion of your average smartphone
into some kind of an ultrasound scanner
which means that if you could actually
deploy computer vision algorithms into
that a smartphone friendly you would
actually have a smartphone that can do
quite a bit of ultrasound diagnosis so
if you can actually have algorithms that
can do this fatal heart anomaly
assessment within the resource
constraint of your average smartphone
your average smartphone becomes you know
a pocket fatal cardio cardiologist so to
speak so to have a algorithm that is
friendly for a mobile system or a mobile
platform the requirements of having you
know a low memory footprint a low
inference time and a low energy
consumption is of importance in this
case we focus primarily on the first
aspect of having a lightweight
architecture we basically use an
architecture that is heavily
squeeze excite blocks and to enhance the
performance we also use trainable
attention blocks at intermediate stages
so we use a very simple engineering
solution to video adaptation here from
the frame level the frame level is on
top and the video is bottom we do not
really use any illicit EMS or other such
temporal methods but simply use time
fusion a special fusion in the time
direction so as to talk of a temporal
fusion kind of a formalism for analysis
of videos the reason we do that is
because it's very difficult to optimize
our hands to work in
resource-constrained settings and do
inference with a reasonable time budget
so fundamentally we consider multiple
squeeze excite blocks have intermediate
attention stages that create
intermediate fully connected layers
which are fused to create a joint
representation and that does your
standard classification so while a lot
of progress has been made for mobile
optimized architectures in recent years
because this is a proof of concept we
start with a really simple squeeze
excite kind of a system so we display
the results for both the frame level and
video level analysis usage of
intermediate attention blocks does
improve performance quite simply because
of enhanced computational bandwidth that
we get because of those fully connected
layers but that said there is quite a
bit of future work to be done because
this is a really simple architecture in
terms of the squeeze excite blocks use
doesn't even do a pruning or a
quantization so these are some of the
other future works that we aspire to do
in future thank you
thank you
any questions
great the